an artist paintbrush can have synthetic
bristles or natural ones made of animal
hair
which type to use is really a matter of
the artist's preference
however painters often tend to use a
natural brush for watercolors a
synthetic brush for acrylics and either
type for oils
these natural hair paint brushes are
made of red Sable which is tail hair
from a species of weasel
red Sable is renowned for its softness
and for spreading paint thinly and
evenly
an experienced head maker performs the
initial steps of making the head of the
paintbrush
she unrolls and straightens out a bundle
of red Sable
then separates enough hairs for one
brush of this size she inserts the hairs
into a metal band called a Ferro made of
nickel plated brass she feels how they
fit in the ferrule if the fit's too
tight she removes some hairs if it's too
loose she adds some
brushes of different shapes require
different tensions
the headmaker takes the correct brass
mold for the brush shape she's making
and inserts the hairs all the way down
into the mold cavity
foreign
[Music]
she ties the roots of the hairs together
with the string
[Music]
then removes them from the mold
she inserts the brush head back into the
ferrule
[Music]
then removes the string
using a template she adjusts What's
called the length out of the brush head
length out is how far the hair is
protrude from the end of the ferrule
after removing stray hairs she aligns
the end of the ferrule with the edge of
the nearly one inch long template and
pulls out or pushes in the hairs until
their tips align with the opposite edge
of the template
[Music]
she completes her specialized work by
suspending the assembled brush head from
a rack
[Music]
another worker now fills a syringe with
epoxy glue
then with the syringe fills the ferrule
with enough glue to submerge the hairs
[Music]
once the glue has dried overnight
another worker Taps the brush head
against a strip of adhesive tape
move any short hairs that didn't adhere
he dips the hairs into a solution of
starch and water
and works the solution into all the
hairs by massaging the head on a towel
Arch allows the hairs to be trained to a
permanent shape
she makes this particular pointed shape
by spinning the head
then smoothing the hairs with her
fingers
[Music]
starch dries overnight locking in the
shape
to make the paint brush handle a worker
in search Birch dowels in a pegboard
then mounts the board upside down on a
dipping machine
this machine submerges the dowels in
black lacquer paint
after one day of drying time there's a
second dip part way this time in silver
paint
the machine has markings to indicate how
deep to dip the dowels for each color
[Music]
after another day of drying time there's
a third dip this time part way in black
paint this creates a black handle with a
silver stripe
once the last coat of black paint dries
a worker uses a pad printer to stamp
lettering on the handle with quick dry
silver ink
one stamp simultaneously applies the
manufacturer's name the brush hair
material the size of the brush and the
series number
[Music]
the brush head onto the handle then the
worker sets the brush aside for a couple
of hours until the glue partially dries
to a tacky state
because the next step crimping would
crack the fully dried hardened glue
[Music]
the worker inserts the ferrule into a
crimping machine which has been loaded
with a die that's the correct diameter
for this brush handle the machine crimps
the ferrule tightly to the handle
attaching it permanently
once that glue hardens the paintbrush is
finally ready
from this point onward it's in the
artist's hands
[Music]
in the 17th and 18th centuries most
wealthy people in Europe and America had
at least one finely crafted game table
in the drawing room for cards and
conversation after dinner
today game tables aren't just for the
wealthy but for anyone who enjoys this
fun and functional furniture
thank you
This Modern game table does double duty
flip the game top over and it becomes a
dining table when it comes to space
saving this table's a game changer
a saw carves kiln-dried Maple boards
into thick strips
helped by a laser scanner so the saw can
make clean and judicious cuts
[Music]
an equipment operator scrutinizes the
strips for knots and other defects and
marks them with orange chalk
another scanner detects the orange marks
enabling a saw to cut around the defects
as it chops the strips into shorter
lengths
the next worker dips one side of the
strips in polyvinyl acetate a super
strong glue
the next worker arranges the strips in a
specific order alternating the grain to
balance the woods expansion and
contraction forces
he clamps them tightly together and
allows the glue to set
workers sand the top and bottom and trim
the sides to produce one of the rim
segments
a computerized router now moves from one
segment to the next as it carves slots
for poker chips and drinks
it then drills holes in the sides for
the wooden dowels that will be used to
join the eight table segments
the segments are now ready for assembly
a worker pipes high strength adhesive in
grooves along the edges and into the
dowel holes
he inserts the dowels in the holes in
one side of each segment
he arranges the segments in a circular
pattern and inserts the dowels in the
corresponding holes
[Music]
Rim segments tightly together with a
strap clamp
and leaves the glued configuration to
cure overnight
this permanently bonds the table Rim
segments
the next day a computerized router
rounds the outside of the rim
[Music]
it also trims the inside of the rim and
forms a channel for the insertion of the
center of the game table
the game table Rim is now complete
with the rim now game side down
the next member of the team pipes more
of the super adhesive into the inner
Channel
[Music]
he inserts the dining table surface
Maple Center has been Precision cut to
fit into the groove in the rim
[Music]
using a rubber mallet he Taps the table
top to entrench it more firmly in the
groove
he flips the table top back to the game
side
and install 16 screws on an angle to
tighten the top to the rim
[Music]
the screws serve as a clamp system to
hold the table Center in place as the
glue cures
[Music]
with the center now bonded to the rim a
worker sprays a base color and then a
wood stain onto both sides
this highlights the character of the
wood and gives it a warm tone
a worker then applies two coats of a
urethane varnish
and Sands the Finish between the coats
then workers assemble a pedestal base
[Music]
install a piece of laminate in a stained
Maple frame
this creates a storage compartment under
the table top
as well as providing a foundation for
the table top to sit on
[Music]
transfers the pedestal base to the table
Foundation
they bolt them together which creates
the support structure for the table top
[Music]
back to the game tabletop a worker
installs a cloth covered padded insert
[Music]
this will serve as a smooth and cushy
surface for card play
[Music]
and with that workers finally transfer
the game tabletop to the base
the games can now begin
[Music]